As 2020 comes to a close, Netflix is finishing
out the year with a brand-new assortment of
television shows, original films, beloved
classics, documentaries, and more to keep
you entertained and occupied.
Here are all the best movies and TV shows
coming to Netflix in December 2020.
Right at the beginning of the month, Mank,
the newest film from acclaimed director David
Fincher, arrives on December 4.
Mank tells the story of famed screenwriter
Herman J. Mankiewicz, played by Gary Oldman,
as he writes the classic drama film Citizen
Kane.
It also details Mankiewicz's personal battles
with director Orson Welles as Citizen Kane
was in production and up to its theatrical
debut in 1941.
"What is it a writer says?
Tell the story you know."
With a supporting cast that includes Amanda
Seyfried, Lily Collins, Charles Dance, and
more, as well as a new original score from
frequent Fincher collaborators Trent Reznor
and Atticus Ross, there's no doubt that Mank
will be a movie to watch as awards season
begins.
On December 11, musical theater fans will
be able to stream Ryan Murphy's The Prom,
adapted from the award-winning Broadway musical
of the same name.
Featuring megawatt stars like Meryl Streep,
James Corden, and Nicole Kidman, The Prom
centers around Broadway actors longing for
the illustrious days of their past who journey
to a small Indiana town to help a high school
student be allowed to take her girlfriend
to prom.
A few days later, on December 18, Chadwick
Boseman's final film will arrive on Netflix.
The world was stunned in August 2020 when
the Black Panther star passed away from stage
IV colon cancer, and his final performance
will come in Ma Rainey's Black Bottom, the
true story of a music legend and one difficult
day in the recording studio.
The film stars Viola Davis as Ma Rainey, an
iconic blues singer, and Boseman co-stars
as the aspirational and determined trumpeter
Levee.
Finally, just before Christmas, George Clooney's
post-apocalyptic thriller The Midnight Sky
will hit Netflix on December 23.
It tells the tale of a scientist in the Arctic
who's racing against time to stop a group
of astronauts from returning home to a global
disaster.
If you're holed up with your family this Christmas
and looking for a new series to binge, Netflix
has no shortage of exciting options.
Netflix will kick off the month with a continuation
of its series The Movies That Made Us, but
this time, it has a festive twist; Holiday
Movies.
Holiday Movies That Made Us will hit the service
on December 1.
Shortly thereafter, the anticipated fourth
season of Nick Kroll's hit animated series
Big Mouth will arrive on December 4, followed
by the premiere of Selena: The Series, which
tells the story of the Tejano singer's life
before a former friend killed her in 1995,
when Selena was just 23 years old.
If you're a fan of thrillers, you'll want
to check out The Mess You Leave Behind, created
by Elite writer Carlos Montero.
The series hits Netflix on December 11.
On the flip side, if you're a music fan looking
for lighter fare, you won't want to miss the
second series of Song Exploder, which interviews
singer-songwriters like Lin-Manuel Miranda
and Alicia Keys and is based on the podcast
of the same name.
Song Exploder arrives on December 15.
On Christmas Day, Netflix subscribers will
get the best gift of all: Bridgerton, the
first product of showrunner Shonda Rhimes'
huge deal with the streaming service.
Narrated by Dame Julie Andrews as the gossipmonger
Lady Whistledown, Bridgerton follows the ins
and outs of high society in London, and is
sure to draw in fans of Rhimes' previous fare
like Scandal and Grey's Anatomy.
"My name is Lady Whistledown.
You don't know me and never shall."
Finally, on December 31, just before 2020
comes to an end, you can stream the fourth
and final season of the Kiernan Shipka starring
series Chilling Adventures of Sabrina.
Aside from new original films, Netflix is
adding a ton of beloved classics in December
2020.
If you're a fan of quirky romantic comedies,
you'll definitely want to check out 50 First
Dates, which stars frequent collaborators
Drew Barrymore and Adam Sandler as a couple
facing a unique relationship hurdle.
50 First Dates will be available to stream
beginning on December 1.
If you want to relive your childhood with
some of Spielberg's best films, ET the Extra-Terrestrial,
Jurassic Park, and Jurassic Park III will
be available on Netflix as well all hitting
the streamer on the first of the month.
Dan Brown enthusiasts will be happy to hear
that both of the author's Tom Hanks-led adaptations,
The Da Vinci Code and Angels and Demons, will
hit Netflix in December 2020.
Meanwhile, if you loved Jon Favreau and Roy
Choi's Chef Show, you'll want to check out
Favreau's film Chef, which built the friendship
between Choi and the director.
All of the above hit Netflix on December 1.
After that, the acclaimed films Nocturnal
Animals and Lee Daniels' The Butler arrive
on Netflix in the middle of the month, on
December 16.
And just as December draws to a close, you
can revisit the animated flick Rango, which
arrives on December 28.
Next month, you can tuck into everything from
a massive reality TV show marathon to a much-beloved
sci-fi series that's been around forever.
On December 1, seasons 1 and 2 of the dating
show Are You the One? and seasons 1 and 2
of tattoo competition Ink Masters will join
Netflix.
Two weeks later, on December 15, the first
two seasons of Black Ink Crew New York, about
a tattoo shop in Harlem, and seasons 1 and
2 of Teen Mom 2 join the fray.
A couple of seasons of MTV's The Challenge
seasons 10 and 13, specifically will arrive
that same day.
If you're looking for a gritty new drama to
binge and want to expand your horizons beyond
the United States, you'll definitely want
to check out season one of Kings of Jo'burg,
a South African drama about the crime world
of Johannesburg that arrives on Netflix on
December 4.
And if a tried-and-true series is what you're
after this December, set aside some time to
watch ten seasons of Stargate SG-1, which
hits the platform on the first of the month.
And those still reeling from the death of
Jeopardy! host Alex Trebek, who passed away
on November 8, 2020 after battling cancer,
can revisit some of Trebek's best moments
on December 18 when a slew of Jeopardy challenge
runs and tournaments all arrive on Netflix.
If you're a fan of hard-hitting documentaries
and or gut-busting stand-up specials, you're
in for a treat on Netflix in December 2020.
Those who can't get enough of medical fare
like ER and House will definitely love The
Surgeon's Cut, which follows real-life surgical
pioneers as they discover new medical breakthroughs.
The docuseries hits the service on December
9.
In search of something more uplifting?
Try out Giving Voice, arriving to Netflix
on December 11.
It tells the true story of the annual August
Wilson monologue competition, which allows
lucky young winners to perform original works
on Broadway.
True crime buffs, however, will want to free
up their schedules on December 16, as that's
when The Ripper drops on Netflix.
The documentary follows real-life witnesses
and investigators as they recall how the Yorkshire
Ripper, described as "a modern-day Jack the
Ripper," tormented northern England in the
late '70s.
Meanwhile, Netflix will also give a voice
to some fresh new faces in stand-up comedy.
On December 1, Natalie Palamides will make
her Netflix debut with Nate - A One Man Show,
where she uses an alter-ego for her stand-up.
The very next day, on December 2, Ari Eldjarn
and Hazel Brugger also step into the world
of Netflix original specials with the premieres
of their respective specials Pardon My Icelandic
and Tropical.
And finally, if you're looking to celebrate
New Year's Eve with some laughs, load up Netflix's
Best Stand-Up of 2020 - a compilation of "the
funniest jokes from comedians in the US, Canada,
Australia and New Zealand that have launched
specials in 2020."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about what to
watch on your favorite streaming platforms
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.